welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we break down movies new
game releases TV shows and comic books
with Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
right around the corner and the Phantom
Menace at fever pitch I thought it was
time to look at the sequel trilogy that
we could have gotten at Disney not
bought Lucasfilm and steered the saga in
their own direction throughout this
video we'll be discussing the original
ideas for the sequel trilogy and what
happened to the characters in it there
will be heavy spoilers here in whilst
these movies will probably never see the
light of day we will be discussing
aspects of the Disney trilogy so if you
aren't fully caught up then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of George Lucas's original
Star Wars sequel trilogy
okay so let's cast our minds all the way
back to 2012 and the sixth official Star
Wars Celebration the force was strong
the cosplayers were capturing the vibe
of a galaxy far far away and series
creator George Lucas was making a
surprise appearance
- apparently promote the Clone Wars TV
show however behind the scenes
Lucas was also in attendance to talk to
Mark Hamill and Carrie Fisher about
working together on a brand new Star
Wars trilogy that would pick up after
the events of Return of the Jedi after
coming up with some ideas for the series
Lucas had hand-picked oscar-winning
screenwriter Michael Arndt to work
alongside Empire Strikes Back and Return
of the Jedi writer Lawrence Kasdan to
start working on a script for Episode
seven and he decided that now was the
time to move ahead with the franchise
Fisher and Hamill both agreed to return
and even Harrison Ford who had up until
this point been pretty unenthusiastic
about the entire series was contacted to
make a comeback sounds great right well
there was also something going on behind
the scenes that Lucas wasn't being too
transparent about and that was the fact
that he was trying to sell his company
he knew that the idea of an episode 7
would make the company worth way more
and later in the air the Disney /
lucasfilm takeover entered its final
stages of acquisition we all know how
that turned out but Lucas let a few of
the Disney execs see treatments for the
new trilogy showing that he had fully
fleshed out ideas that they could easily
take and spin off into
a new direction when going back and
looking at them it's clear that Disney
did pick up some of these ideas and
there's actually quite a lot that we
know about the original plans and
they're a really interesting read the
trilogy was to center around Sam and
Kyra two teenagers that were going to be
the grandchildren of Anakin Skywalker
we have concept art of the two and it's
clear that they are the children of Han
and Leia with both bearing a strong
resemblance to the couple though this
has never been officially stated just
just yet search your feelings you know
it to be true
Sam is handy with a gun whereas a lot of
the art of Kyra that we have shows her
practicing her Jedi training and gaining
strength in the force the three
trilogies all together were going to be
about the father the child and the
grandchildren of the same family and
Lucas and Kathleen Kennedy were ecstatic
about centering a franchise around a
female Jedi so yeah no matter what we
were going to get Mary Sue I mean ray
just in a slightly different form and
connected more with the original trilogy
it's also said that Sam did go on to
become the inspiration for Finn
so like the force awakens we work on to
have a male and female protagonist Kyra
similar to Rey was going to be a
scavenger labeled as the ultimate
outsider
whereas Sam would be a pirate and marine
expert that too helped to discover the
mysteries of the past initially it was
thought that for the first film there
would be children but Lucas decided to
age them up slightly so that this wasn't
a case one more of the Phantom Menace
even though I'm pretty sure the reason
that that movie sucked was because of
George or Binks and not a kid podracing
but hey that's just me when writing the
screenplay Arendt said that he
constantly ran into the problem of Luke
Skywalker and that when he showed up in
the movie no matter what he took over
the entire piece this is exemplified in
a statement that aren't made when
discussing the previous revisions of the
older treatment he said early on I tried
to write versions of the story where in
brackets Rey is at home her home is
destroyed and then she goes on the road
and meets Luke and then she goes and
kicks the bad guys ass it just never
worked and I struggled with this this
was back in 2012 and it just felt like
every time Luke came in and entered the
movie he just took over it suddenly you
didn't care about your main character
anymore because Oh F at Luke Skywalker's
here
I want to see what he's going to do this
clearly carried over to the force
awakens as Luke is in it for basically a
minute and even then his presence bears
a strong shadow over the entire film
with his location being one of the main
MacGuffins similar to the Episode seven
that we eventually got the creative team
decided that it was best to have Luke
hiding out in a remote Jedi Temple and
we have some George Lucas approved
concept out of this that beautifully
shows what the location would have
looked like in the book the art of the
last Jedi Phil stole stack reveals that
Luke's appearance in the Disney trilogy
drew heavily from the 2012 treatment and
from statements and interviews we know
that this self-imposed exile was due to
the betrayal of a former student Colonel
Kurtz in Apocalypse Now was listed as a
big inspiration for the portrayal of
Luke and similar to the last Jedi his
x-wing was submerged underwater the film
was supposed to have two driving forces
as initially it would center around the
hunt for Darth Vader's remains which
would eventually lead the main
characters to the location of Luke this
involves searching the underwater
wreckage of the Death Star which would
uncover information on the sacred Jedi
sites in the galaxy that would
eventually lead them to the temple
the protagonists would venture to the
Death Star underwater in the Millennium
Falcon and from here Kira would swim
herself in order to find the location of
the artifacts and this journey is
massively developed in the concept art
with there being the throne room and
trenches in the throne room
Kira finds a map that says where the
Jedi are hiding and this would lead her
to Luke as for han and Leia very little
is known about their roles in the film
however Harrison Ford did lay at lgq
that during his first call with George
about the project that the character
would die during the movie Ford said it
was proposed that I might make another
appearance as han Solo
I think it was mentioned even in the
first call that he would not survive
that's something I'd been arguing for
some period of time so I said okay
similar to the force awakens han and
Leia had drifted apart over time and the
story was very much about the two coming
together with on stating that he was
fighting for Han to survive the film he
fought for this as it would have given
the couple a happy ending but it seems
like the production was torn on this and
as we know in the end we got the death
of the character now the villain of the
trilogy was originally going to be a
character similar to Darth Talon from
the legacy comic series that was behind
seduction and turning of Luke's pupil
Lucas loved the character and there was
even going to be a hidden appearance of
her in the cancelled Darth Maul game the
character was meant to right the wrongs
of Maul and would basically be similar
in nature but with far more character
development to the original film Ian
McCrae who worked on the concept art for
the character said the following when
discussing them the tattoos are a lot
similar they follow a rhythm and they
flow and that's the evil thing
puppeteering her from behind George
Lucas later said it's like poetry you
know they rhyme leann rimes yeah you may
not have said that
there are a number of storyboards in
which the character appeared in
including the one where she seduced
Luke's pupil and also another where
she's standing on the left hand side of
a bar at this point she actually appears
exactly like da Talon so there may have
been thoughts of adopting that character
fully into the role though we don't have
confirmation on this she saw up operated
in the underworld and though she didn't
have a master she was strong in the dark
side using her beauty and sexuality as a
weapon r2d2 and c3po were going to be
split up for the film's and Lucas also
wanted a focus on the microbiotic world
of the universe with a strong focus on
the Wills which I'm really really glad
we didn't get the door was so bad now
the Wills are basically the things that
control the universe and these bacterial
sized creatures feed off the force the
movies were going to be heavily centered
around midi-chlorians and what creates
the force honestly I'm glad that this
wasn't carried through as I've always
been of the thought that the force
shouldn't be explained and we don't
really need to know why it controls the
universe it just kind of is Lucas wanted
the films to be much more ethereal and
for the main characters to be basically
just vehicles at the worlds travel
around in they will the universe get it
because it's really clever and Lucas
said that he saw her as the characters
were just caused and the Wills were the
drivers with the midi-chlorians being
what connects the two Lucas said that he
laid the groundwork for this in the
Phantom Menace and that he regrets not
being able to build on it any further
he does admit that he knows that fans
would have hated it but that at least he
would have gotten to tell a complete
story that was initially set up in
Episode one according to Mark Hamill
Leia was going to be trained by Luke
before the Jedi Master was finally
killed in Episode nine Luke was the last
Jedi and he had decided to reform the
group and during this he had made his
own academy full of Padawans Luke was
going to be killed by a people known as
the Jedi killer that turn on him and the
finale would involve the villain working
with the Doc Talon character before both
were taken down by Kira and Leia now
this point is all still very
underdeveloped but it is reportedly
where the trilogy was going to be
heading there were also rumors that
Kathleen Kennedy did want to bring
Emperor Palpatine back in the original
plans and as we know from the rise of
Skywalker the character will be back for
the final film overall it's very
interesting hearing what we could have
got but honestly it doesn't sound all
that different from the final things
that we got to see play out I think that
Disney sort of hand-picked their
favorite elements from this treatment
and then moved it over to their trilogy
taking it in the direction that they
wanted well there are a lot of
criticisms around the new trilogy most
notably the last Jedi I do think that
what we ended up getting was better than
what we would have got with Lucas the
entire Wills element for me just ruins
the choices that the characters made and
it sort of takes away a lot of the big
twists in the franchise such as Darth
Vader's turn and Luke's struggle with
fighting his father reducing it to just
yeah they were mind-controlled by
bacteria I can see a lot more fan
outrage over this but some of the
iconography in the concept art is
awesome and I love the underwater
exploration of the Death Star especially
the Millennium Falcon if you're asking
why the Falcon was in the water
and trust me I asked that as well they
said it was because it was airtight for
space so yeah it could be airtight for
underwater too like never mind that's
that's a pointless detail in a movie
that's never going to be made in the end
it's awesome seeing what we could have
got though but if I had to choose
between the two I probably would go for
the Disney version even though they keep
copyright striking all my videos at the
moment I see you Mickey and yes I will
still be a Disney shell leave your
thoughts below on the original sequel
trilogy ideas and let me know whether
you would have liked to have seen this
version or not if you enjoyed this video
then give it a thumbs up
all the kid gets it and I just want to
give a huge thank you to everyone who
voted yesterday to get this video made
if you want to watch more Star Wars
stuff that make sure you check out our
full breakdown of the Mandalorian
episode 3 at the end and if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey well head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the marble
phase 3 part 2 boxer blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war
endgame Captain Marvel and more and all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the original sequel trilogy
in the comment section below
when it's gonna be chosen on the 15th of
December and the Cell be shipped out
from the intro ever gets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you